JULY THIRD ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING --
WE HAVE SEVENTEEN BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BIGELOW PRESENT BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH CALDERON CARRILLO CHAU.
DEEP.
EGGMAN FONG GABRIEL.
GARCIA.
MISSION.
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK.
RIVAS YEAH.
GREAT THERE'S A QUORUM MISS
RUBIO I THINK YOU HAVE THE ONLY
BILL PRESENTATION -- IT IS SB
THREE SIXTEEN AND ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WITH THE MOTION.
BY MISTER BONTA SECOND -- BY
MISTER CALDERON -- SECOND.
I'M SORRY BY MISTER BRO.
I HEARD IT DIDN'T SEE IT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M HERE
PROBABLY PRESENTING SB THREE ONE
SIX THIS BILL ALLOWS PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
TO PRINT THE TELEPHONE NUMBER
FOR THE NATIONAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOTLINE.
IN THE BACK OF STUDENT ID CARDS
TO REFORMAT STUDENT ID CARDS AT
ALL PUBLIC.
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS WILL
RESULT IN A MINOR ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND.
OR GENERAL FUND COST IN THE LOW
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. TO SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW MEASURE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHILE
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION AT THIS
TIME WE NOTE THAT THE BILL COULD
CREATE A OUR STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE IN THE LOW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PROP NINETY
GENERAL FUND [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
DO YOU SEEN QUESTIONS.
NOT SURE WHY THE SUPPORT OF
CONSENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU JUST THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION I ASK FOR ACT
LIKE A TOWN ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT I'VE MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE A SECOND BY MISTER
BIGELOW MAN SECRETARY WE PLEASE
READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SB 629-924-05390 THREE FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BIBLE FIVE BIBLE
SIX AND SIX EIGHTY ONE AND I GET
THAT ON ANY ROLL CALL -- MA'AM
SURGERY WE READ THE BILLS THAT
ARE REMOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
SB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT TO THIRTY THREE
FIFTY ONE THREE SIXTY SEVEN FIVE
EIGHTEEN AND SIX TWENTY TWO IF
YOU'RE HERE.
TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO ONE THE BILL'S IT
BEEN MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
WHERE THE AUTHOR HAS WAY
PRESENTATION.
WHICH IS ALL OF THEM -- YOU MAY
DO SO AT THIS TIME.
SEE NONE THAT CONCLUDES THE
RATIONS COMMITTEE